liyan your bio you say that the writers
that you've seen make it or have success
often know their strengths and
weaknesses are very self-aware that's
great but who do they actually trust to
tell them the truth about that because
so many people say oh you're so
wonderful but there's like a hidden
agenda and then there's vice versa
they're sort of the poisonous playmates
of course you have to find the people
that you trust I mean listen the reality
is that this is a two-sided coin on one
side nobody likes confrontation nobody
wants to be the bad friend that told you
that you know you stink you sweat too
much so change shirt and like nobody
wants to have those conversation about
what doesn't work because they want to
be your friends and they want to have
wine with you and they want to kick back
and they don't want the weight of they
said something uncomfortable to you on
the other end you have the people who
are not at your level who just want to
kind of hang on and see where you're
going and everything you do is great and
brilliant fantastic it really is a hunch
it really is about finding the people
that you trust to tell you the good in
bed I generally don't and this is me and
this is not politically correct I find
that you can't be on the side of the
writer on the side of the sail at the
same time which is why I work the way
that I work because if I'm invested in
selling something my first priority
stops being the writer and it starts
being putting money in my bank right so
I think that you have to find people who
are whose job is to be honest with you
it used to be managers that were a lot
more hands-on with creative development
career development but because the
business model changed so aggressively
in 2008 after the 2008 strike very few
still have that luxury
you know managers used to have a small
roster 15 20 people now we're seeing I
see many of my friends in management who
used to have smaller rosters suddenly
with 30 40 50 clients because now it
takes twice the time to break a writer
or sell a script for half the money so
you have to load your roster if you want
to keep making the same money that you
did so you have to find people who are
not invested in necessarily in making
money off of you but are invested in
your long-term best interest
who will be honest with you who will not
be who are not competing with you
competition element is always tough
because the moment you have competition
there inevitably and subconsciously
other emotions that come into play that
may taint why someone is saying
something so you really do have to find
your team that you can always go back to
I had a writer years ago who wrote a
script that had a lot of heat on it and
he was signed by CIA and I kept telling
him you have to get a manager you have
to get somebody who's on your side
who'll give it to you straight
I wasn't coaching at that time yet but
you know he came to me through scripts
arc which I was running for six and a
half years we became quite friendly I
gave him some advice my advice was find
somebody on your side not on the side of
selling the script ultimately the script
fizzled out and he fizzled out in such a
drastic and dramatic fashion he made
such mistakes that nobody at the big
agency that signed him was going to stop
and train him on it or talk him through
it or consider the option or say don't
you ever freaking say that you know he
was effectively put on stage to perform
didn't know how to perform thought that
he did which was a huge mistake
and so everything fizzled if he had
somebody in his ear who was coaching him
who was training him who knew what the
hell they were talking about that
mistake wouldn't have happened but he
was you know his his movie that or his
screenplay that was very much the talk
of the town disappeared overnight he
fizzled and was dropped by the agency
from one day to the next based on very
simple mistakes that the writer made
that had he had somebody invested in him
and not in just the money would have
been different
you